[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisi ravi de vous retrouver pour
sauver huitième numéro tout de suite le
sommaire de ce jeudi 8 novembre le dos à
paris de thoiry s'est illuminée pour
l'hiver selon l'antenne répartis sur six
hectares ce festival de lanternes toi
régulière sauvage
les festivités ont commencé le 28
octobre et se poursuivre jusqu'au 10
mars le grand prix de vélizy revient au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour une cinquième édition de
la vitesse jusqu'au crash
il y aura du spectacle dimanche 11
novembre et en ce week-end de
commémorations de l'armistice de la
grande guerre nous irons à la découverte
de l'exposition versailles pour
lendemain de la victoire de 1918 pour
cette fin d'année le zoo safari de trois
ris a choisi d'éclairer son parc
le 28 octobre s'est ouvert le festival
des lanternes thouaré lumière sauvage
qui se poursuit jusqu'au 10 mars tout de
suite un sujet de manou varaldo girafe
crapaud pan ou encore lyon entièrement
réalisé à la main et recouvertes de
tissu ses oeuvres uniques s'allume à la
tombée de la nuit
touahri accueille le plus grand festival
de lanternes chinoises en france c'est
de 36 ans
ce chinois de la ville d'eysines gong
kaiku une tradition depuis des centaines
d'années de faire des lanternes et
maintenant avec la technologie moderne
faire des lanternes géantes on a donc
derrière moi une reconstitution du
temple du ciel à beijing qui fait dix
sept mètres de haut en face le château
est mis en valeur avec un spectacle de
sons et lumières avec toujours des
éléments de la culture chinoise présent
fleurs dragon base ou encore lanternes
chinoises jouent vraiment su associer de
que donc la chine et les animaux dont
qui sont propres à thoiry ni imposer et
les animaux auront une expression les
curieux peuvent assister à un spectacle
de la troupe de théâtre de sichuan
on y retrouve des équilibristes
acrobates et transformiste du visage
comme dans le théâtre traditionnel
chinois ils se produisent en face de
l'une des créatures phare de l'événement
un dragon de 65 mètres de long le
visiteur peut ensuite continuer l
aventure en traversant la forêt remplie
d'animaux lumineux en spectacle de plus
de 600 lantern répartis en 30 tableaux
de jour comme de nuit c'est magnifique
quand on voit le travail les détails que
dessus on est en paix on est bien c'est
trop bien
tout au long du parcours d'un kilomètre
5 dans les jardins du château des
dizaines d'autres animaux tels et
volatiles zèbre ou encore iguane ces
animaux captent le regard des visiteurs
parfois venus de loin
c'est vraiment magique et magnifique
c'est une super belle expérience toute
une facette de la culture chinoise à
découvrir à thoiry pendant cinq mois
jusqu'au 10 mars
on reste dans la lumière avec le retour
du concours de décorations de noël
demeure pas que vous soyez en logement
individuel ou collectif s'est ouvert à
tous il suffit de vous inscrire avant le
25 novembre par courriel événementiel @
maurepas point fr ou sur le site
internet de la commune morts poids mort
pas point fr rubrique démarches en ligne
pour ceux qui auraient tendu de donner
de la voix ce week end la clé des champs
à plaisir vous invite à un karaoké un
peu spécial le groupe why not sera
derrière vous pour rassurer les morceaux
en live et chauffer votre voix avant
samedi 10 novembre à 20h45
petit tour par les salles
saint-quentinoise cette semaine patrick
jacques de dixmude vous amène au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa qui vient tout juste de
réouvrir ses portes après huit semaines
de fermeture
[Musique]
l'actualité au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
ses autres réouverture après huit
semaines de fermeture suite à un dégât
des eaux qui avaient abîmé la moquette
et les sièges de la salle
nous avons tourné toyer le hall la
moquette les sièges et on va pouvoir
vous accueillir dans un cinéma qui sent
le neuf
pour récupérer les films qu'on avait
prévu de programmer qu'on vous avait
proposé puis qu'on a été obligé
d'annuler à cause de ce dégât des eaux
donc vous pourrez redécouvrir des films
sur grand écran comme les vieux
fourneaux première année mais aussi les
frères sister's de jacques audiard qui
est un vrai film fort un des grands
films de cette fin d'année 2010 8
jacques audiard étant un des grands
réalisateurs français actuellement en
activité
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille sur les
relations entre les hommes la fraternité
et cetera depuis regarde les hommes
tomber son premier film avec trintignant
4x il n'a cessé de travailler cette
matière là des relations entre hommes de
la fraternité au sein de souvent
d'histoire assez difficile et assez
complexe le western semble lui aller
très très bien je vous invite donc à
venir le découvrir
et puis on aura aussi sur la question la
fraternité de manière plus concrète et
contemporaine et commémorative en même
temps les croix de bois
adapté du roman de raymond dorgelès
qu'on vous propose de découvrir en
version restaurée
le samedi 10 novembre à 16 heures et on
aura une petite un petit bonus en début
de projection d'un court métrage
des peuples de 1915 je vous invite donc
à revenir aussi des malles des yeux
d'elsa nous sommes réouvert à très
bientôt aller au pas au trot au galop
chevauchée au sein de l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines c'est ce
que veut développer sky équitation le
centre équestre accueille tous les
publics et même les plus jeunes d'entre
nous nicolas vous nous avez rejoindront
soir bonsoir
alors que propose ce poney club pour les
petits alors l'école à son poney club
destinée aux moins de 6 ans du baby
poney pour les 4-5 ans et un cours
moustiques pour les 2 3 ans un stage se
dérouler pendant les vacances de la
toussaint julien guennec et moniteur
d'équitation écoutez le ça permet de
sensibiliser les enfants pendant une
semaine autour du poney ça permet de
l'ordre développé un petit peu là les
sens des responsabilités tout ça de
pouvoir s'occuper d'un être vivant
voilà c'est vraiment à quelque chose
c'est vraiment la semaine de stage leur
permet vraiment de s'habituer d'avoir
des bons réflexes avec les animaux comme
les grands les cavaliers découvrent
leurs montures les brosses les prépare
très vite ils montrent leurs poneys et
alterne les petites activités slalom
parcours et même un peu de voltige
donc on leur apprend un petit peu
comment se comporter autour du poney à
les familiariser avec l'animal et à
vaincre un petit peu leur première
appréhension
les premiers contacts avec l'animal il
ya ensuite c'est vraiment que du ludique
on leur apprend pas forcément de la
technique mais on leur apprend en
s'amusant
alors comme vous le savez marylène les
vacances de la toussaint sont terminés
mais les activités se poursuivent pour
les 4-5 ans kai équitation fait durer le
plaisir
les trois dimanche de novembre les baby
poney continue de 11h30 à 12h30
pour plus de renseignements rendez vous
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
merci nicolas est bonne balade à poney
merci marie lehn le vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines reçoit le
cinquième grand prix de vélizy dimanche
11 novembre à partir de 13 heures au
programme de la vitesse du keirin de
limites de l'élimination et du scratch
c'est la première épreuve qui compte
pour la coupe d'hiver d'île de france
au total une centaine de coureurs se
disputeront les podiums
jean michel richefort l'organisateur du
grand prix était sur le plateau du 7-8
sport de michael et demi d'euros et les
coureurs viennent spontanément parce que
courir au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour un pistard
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel donc
là ils viennent régulièrement d'ailleurs
toutes les épreuves sont complètes ou
savait qu'on ne peut pas mettre plus de
24 coureurs en piste sur les épreuves
d'endurance et toutes les épreuves sont
complets et nouveauté cette année du
cyclisme artistique finira d'assurer le
spectacle
l'entrée de 3 euros la billetterie se
trouve directement sur place
d'autres rencontres sportives à venir
encourager ce week end le sky grube et
rugby affronte l'entente maisons
laffitte saint germain les toits six
premiers du classement
la rencontre se déroulera dimanche 11
novembre à 15 heures au stade du bout
des clos à maurepas du ballon ovale au
ballon rond les seniors de première
division des clubs de maurepas et de
plaisir s'affrontent dimanche 11
novembre même heure même lieu le stade
du bout des clos à maurepas à 15 heures
on ne pouvait pas passer à côté de ce
centenaire de l'armistice de la première
guerre mondiale
après les différentes commémorations
dans les communes vous pourrez vous
rendre à l'hôtel de ville de versailles
pour leur exposition sur l'après guerre
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
le 11 novembre 1918 l'armistice était
signé mais la grande guerre laisse ses
traces certains soldats mettent
plusieurs mois revenir des tranchées et
la vie quotidienne reste difficile c'est
cette période que la ville de versailles
et le comité des anciens combattants ont
choisi de mettre en avant dans leur
exposition versailles au lendemain de la
victoire de 1918
j'ai voulu me décaler un petit peu en
présentant la pré armistice pour
démontrer d'une part que les soldats ne
sont pas revenus
enfin 18 mai beaucoup 1019 voire plus
tard et puis nous avons voulu quand même
personnaliser cette exposition par des
par une présentation de documents
appartenant aux familles versaillaise
des documents qui s'ajoutent à ceux des
archives municipales départementales et
enrichissent l'exposition
là vous avez un document qui est assez
rare qui est une lettre à l'encré
sympathique de façon à contourner les la
censure souvent donc les soldats les
poilus écrivait alors famille avec de
l'encré sympathique été révélé ce
travail est aussi intergénérationnel
depuis plusieurs années une
collaboration se fait avec les collèges
et les lycées du département
leurs productions font pleinement partie
de l'exposition et présentent leur
propre regard sur cette époque monsieur
de moura donc à rassembler plusieurs
lycées pour les faire travailler sur les
commémorations du centenaire
donc vous avez beaucoup de dessins qui
ont été faits et qui ont été faits par
thèmes ainsi vous avez ce souvenir
combattre souffrir et c'est avec des
des dessins en rapport un travail de
mémoire de partage entre les générations
bien accompli les jeunes et blinois on
s'y travail est une pièce de théâtre
pour accompagner l'exposition le grand
festin s'amener 10 novembre à 20h30 à
l'espace jean racine la ville de
guyancourt met un autre conflit en
lumière celui de 39 45
une deuxième exposition qui se trouve à
la salle d'exposition de la ville ils
sont représentés les oeuvres d'un
collectif mémoire libre de l'atelier
d'arts plastiques de maurepas une
quarantaine d'oeuvres pour parler de la
résistance
reportage de mélanie poker une étoile
jaune souvent symbole toujours
représentatifs de la seconde guerre une
étoile réel et inspirante
francine play a choisi de la béquille
mais des tas de gens pour protester
contre cette fameuse étoile qui
stigmatisait toute une partie de la
population a trouvé le moyen d'en
fabriquer pas forcément avec les jaunes
mais des fois du blancs avec des
inscriptions fantaisiste de façon à dire
bon bah moi aussi j'arbore ça je ne suis
pas mais voilà donc il ya des prénoms il
ya des dates de naissance il ya un
certain nombre de données comme ça qui
sont réels comme francine 25 artistes
ont peint la guerre et ses résistances
acrylique collage impression le
collectif mémoire libre s'est bâtie au
sein de l'atelier d'arts plastiques de
maurepas et a créé une quarantaine de
toiles
c'est une aventure qui a commencé en
2004 ma fille faisait partie d'une
association qui travaillait pour la
mémoire et l'espoir de la résistance est
à l'organiser des colloques des
et des conférences et cetera autour de
ce thème et elle nous a suggéré de
travailler en pâture sur la notion de
résistance
on a travaillé pendant un an voire deux
ans pour certains et on a été nourrie
par des documents que qui était importée
on a eu monsieur stéphane hessel
ambassadeur qui est venu dans notre
atelier la résistance deuxième volet
d'une série d'expositions guyancourt a
choisi cette année de mettre en avant
les guerres ses impressions ses
conséquences c'est pour toujours dans
cet esprit du centenaire rappeler ce
devoir de mémoire c'est important pour
transmettre pour ce désir de transmettre
à toutes les nouvelles générations que
la guerre les doux les douleurs tout ça
existe et que ce n'est pas un acquis et
que tous ensemble nous devons résister
pour que ça continue
que la paix arrive un devoir de mémoire
qui se transmet jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
les actes de résistance exposé à
guyancourt jusqu'au 9 décembre
c'est la fin de cette édition de votre
7,8 choisir merci nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles et des sorties
non
ouais
oh
[Musique]